well french president emmanuel macron
has condemned as inexcusable the brutal
repression of algerian protesters by
paris police on 60 years ago on october
17 1961 officers carried out a deadly
crackdown on a demonstration by tens of
thousands of algerians in one of the
darkest episodes in post-war france
some historians say more than 200 people
were killed in the violence
it's the first time a french president
has attended a memorial ceremony for the
algerians killed on that night emmanuel
macron joined relatives of the victims
in paying tribute
60 years ago at this spot bodies were
fished out from the seine river
an estimated 25 000 algerians rallied
peacefully in protest against a curfew
imposed on them alone
police responded without mercy arresting
nearly twelve thousand and killing
dozens throwing their bodies into the
river
many others were taken away to sorting
centers and then deported
saeed up two was there that night
the police came
when they got to us they started to
massacre people hitting them with batons
on the head then kicking them in the
head with their shoes
never seen anything like that
the violence occurred in the final year
of france's violent attempt to keep
algeria as one of its colonies
for decades successive administrations
ignored the massacre president macron's
condemnation of the killings was only
issued in a written statement and did
not include an apology
this year's commemoration took place
amid diplomatic tensions between both
countries over their history